Freaks and Geeks got a criminally short
run of only 18 episodes after its
September 1999 debut before NBC pulled
the pluck meanwhile critics were nearly
unanimous in their love for the show and
two different episodes were nominated
for outstanding writing in a comedy
series at the Emmys you want to make out
or something all guys want to make out
the Emmy that Freaks and Geeks actually
won outstanding casting for a comedy
series shouldn't come as a surprise
given that its Ensemble included
multiple soon to be a-listers there are
no shortage of coming of age shows that
look back at a previous generation but
Freaks and Geeks stood out both for its
honest depiction of the less popular
crowd as well as paying tribute to its
era without descending into parody oh
and its creator and executive producer
that would be Paul feig and Jud appau
respectively who would become some of
the biggest comedic voices in Hollywood
a short time later